here's what i prepared earlier okay
actually i told her why i didn't prepare
it earlier
um i mocked up what we did on the basis
because this is how things work in
reality
i want to point out some things to you
and we're going to discuss them and
understand why they're significant
mathematically okay and i'd like you to
follow along as we label these on okay
i asked you to point out like literally
put a point
on the four spots on the graph where our
lines
intersect here in the middle okay these
four spots
let me explain the way they work okay
the first pair of spots they're in pairs
the first pair of spots i'm going to
look at are these two here
where this line the red one which is our
you know that's a premium product our
expensive line intersects with
our too cheap line okay like that
right so you've got a point down here
it's called the pmc
the pmc
the pmc stands for the point of marginal
cheapness the point of marginal
cheapness now let me explain
okay what is this line here the very
first one we drew
okay this line represents this thing's
too cheap clearly it's a bit dodgy but
maybe it fell off the back of a truck
it's illegal something like that
okay it's cheap it's not a good thing
right
so this line represents i don't want to
buy this product
i don't want to buy it but it does
intersect with
a very very small number of people
who still think i think this thing's
pricey
okay that's the intersection point we've
got the price the point
of marginal cheapness down here okay
it's not a really good point
because you know you're not making that
much of a profit it's a lower price over
here
but it's okay all right you've got a
pretty low number of people here
who flat out won't buy the product
because it's too cheap okay
that's the pmc over here on the opposite
side is the pme
if this is the point of marginal
cheapness what do you think pmb stands
for
point of view yeah marginal
expensiveness that's not a real word but
anyhow it gets across
the idea right that in between here and
here
we've transitioned across now people
thinking yeah this is actually kind of
more on the expensive end of things
right
in between these and this is not on the
diagram
in between them here right this is what
we call
the acceptable price range the
acceptable
price range and it's very important that
you get it's a range it's a range
there isn't a single right price
for whatever object or service you're
selling okay
and all companies know this example if
you go to maccas
right how much would you expect a big
mac to cost roughly
seven bucks in a meal okay i didn't eat
a meal seven bucks i think that's
reasonable
okay at different times different things
right and here's the thing though
if you go to like caster hillbackers
okay
and then if you're on a parramatta
westfield market and then if you go to
penrith mackeres they're all gonna give
you
different prices right because there is
a range here
right in france they're all pricey yeah
they're all pricing
differently sometimes quite
significantly
i'll come back to the point remind me at
the end of this anyhow
in between our pmc
and our pm e over here
any spot within here that's actually an
okay price that's an ok
but there are two other points that are
important here this one up the top
is called the ipp and this one down the
bottom is really really important it's
called the opp
so the ipp you can see it from the
screen it stands for
the indifference price point it's the
indifference price point
because this is clearly an important
point where these two worlds intersect
you've got some people who are kind of
like you're cheaper people and they're
looking for lower prices and over here
your art market
people and this is where you've got the
intersection between those right
but it's called the indifference price
point because
unlike these lower lines here right the
too expensive and the two
inexpensive line it's not gonna like
it's not a hard
i would not buy that at all well i
definitely must buy this it's kind of
yeah i'm kind of in between i'm not a
keynote there yeah okay
so that's why it's called the
indifference price point because often
it makes people well it's indifferent
to it i'm not clearly in one boat or
another
but this guy down here the opp much more
important
if there is a single point on here that
we should figure that's
the best price it's the optimal price
point
right down here okay and let me try and
explain why
what are these two lines that i'm eating
on this graph it's the blue and purple
on mine it's the blue and black
what are those lines look at the key
it's it's the line which is too cheap
too inexpensive
right versus the line which is too
costly too expensive right down here
this is the point that minimizes
both in a balanced way okay it's got the
least number of people
who reject it because too cheap and the
least are people who eject it because
it's too
expensive right does that make sense so
that's the
best if there is a single best point
that's the best point we call that
the optimal price point you've got this
here which is kind of minimizing your
people who won't buy it
these guys over here there's a spectrum
right
back on where you wrote the pmc the
disadvantages of the pmc are
because it's a lower price right what
does that mean about your profit margin
it's it's smaller isn't it you're not
going to make as much profit
and you're up market people who they
want a more expensive product because it
means quality
less of them will buy them because it's
too cheap over here
what does this mean this means it's
going to be more expensive what are our
disadvantages
think about the disadvantages i told you
here which are
lower profit margin and you get rid of
your up market people
what are the disadvantages over here
okay some people just gonna say i can't
afford it can't afford it i don't have
that kind of money to throw around
and in addition to that because less
people are gonna buy it from the get-go
because it's more expensive
you've got less ability for word of
mouth to kind of spread around and say
hey wow
you know this apple watch really is the
best thing that ever happened to me
not that many people are going to say it
because it's just too expensive to even
get into the market
yeah okay so
all of that is how we understand all the
prices this has a name by the way
i'll just scroll at the top you might
want to jot it down uh this is named
after a dutch
economist called peter van westenbaum
right you can go look at this
uh it's called a price sensitivity meter
and it's all different based on whatever
kind of object you're charging for
whether it's an
apple watch or the cost to your mobile
phone plan
or a big mac meal okay